now that they've done x-men Days of
Future past it should somehow find a way
to do the Phoenix saga in a movie
because we haven't actually seen it on
the big screen shut up we haven't we
have not x-men Days of Future past two
x-men Days of Future past is the newest
x-men movie directed by Bryan Singer who
directed x-men in X - x-men United feel
like it's The Return of the King if he
pulls off Days of Future past well if
the movies good if not we're like
alright that's the guy who directed
Superman Returns I gotta say this movie
has been getting really good reviews I
was going into a gun alright maybe it's
good the movie to me was a bit
disappointing for one very huge reasons
because from now on from now until the
end of my life I have to go through life
knowing not theorizing but knowing that
x-men 3 would have been awesome if Bryan
Singer had done it holy Days of
Future past is badass guys Bryan Singer
still makes good x-men movies in dayz
feature past me it starts out in the
future and the future looks really grim
it's shitty it's like terminator but
sentinels are running the place only way
out of this is to send Wolverines
consciousness back in time to 1973 I
believe it is - his younger body - get
Charles Xavier and Magneto together so
they can somehow stop this shitty
feature that they know from ever
happening not only is it pulled off well
but James McAvoy is Charles Xavier is
awesome one of the things I loved about
x-men first class is that they humanize
Charles Xavier
Charles Xavier as we always knew him was
his mentor figure you know he had the
answers to everything he was really wise
somehow you're like I I can't relate to
you but I look up to you next Ben first
class they humanize him and made him a
character you can relate to more this
one they humanize him even more because
he is that his lowest low in life like
imagine at the end of empire strikes
back before Return of the Jedi you know
when they get their plan together and
they get Han out and they kind of you
know start kicking ass again was there a
moment after Empire where everyone was
just depressed you know where everyone's
like there's no hope it's just it's
despair everywhere I don't know but the
fact is Charles Xavier is there in this
movie and I really like that and I like
the Easter eggs movie there are enough
Easter eggs movie for you to be like oh
holy oh holy I like the fact
that there's fanservice and the movie is
exciting the action scenes are really
exciting things happen were you like
that is the volatile situation I'm
looking for good job there was
point the movie rose-like not a lot of
actions happening but I am interested
because I'm interested to see Erik
Lehnsherr and Charles Xavier
not necessarily reconnect but talk and
then something exciting happened again
I'm like alright good timing people but
more than that the movie is really well
it's touching I want to use this phrase
and you're going to know that now I've
become a really sappy cheesy person but
I would not use this phrase if I did not
fully believe it was the best term to
describe the movie x-men Days of Future
past is ultimately about hope watch the
movie you'll say that too it's about
getting Charles Xavier to hope again
it's about hoping for the feature does
magneto have hope is he gonna change the
error of his ways that is is everything
gonna work out you feel the despair you
understand you're like you know Xavier I
get it I feel like if anyone's gonna
about the movies gonna be the fact
that bishops in the movie kind of he
doesn't do much he's in the movie for
the sake of if he wasn't in a Days of
Future past movie that would be weird so
they put him in this movie but he really
doesn't do much I know a lot of people
are like alright we've seen Wolverine as
the main character in all these x-men
movies give someone else a shot I know
what you're saying but you can't deny
the dude's good at it if you sucked at
it that'd be one thing but Hugh Jackman
kills it in these movies Peter Dinklage
as Trask you know the guy who creates
the Sentinels he's ultimately the Tony
Stark of the 70s so I guess he'd be
Howard Stark he was awesome in the movie
too he's not like a main character but
he's a very important character it's one
of those things where I give Peter
Dinklage so much credit Trask is not a
dwarf he's not in the comic books but
Peter Dinklage plays him in this movie
he's feel like Peter Dinklage does such
a good job at acting that they were like
I don't care the size of the guy he's
the best guy for the role you watch the
movie you can't argue it you're like
yeah who else would yeah Peter Dinklage
I feel like that breaks so much ground
like sighs or not it's about acting
ability and I love that this was a
big project to take on honestly a lot of
directors probably were approached with
this they were like I didn't I don't
even know how to begin but Brian singer
did a great job doing it he shows that
he does really great x-men movies from
these start the beginning credits starts
doing that theme it's all done better
Dana and Lana
da-da-da-da-da-da-da
I can't sing for but I was like
that's the x---two x-men United theme oh
my god he was just cool to hear
again it was like Bryan Singer going out
of the way is my franchise not
only does he say that from the beginning
credits but he professes it and proves
it throughout the movie there is a post
credit scene in this movie that
personally got me really jacked up it's
my favorite since Nick Fury director of
shield came out and talked to Iron Man
x-men Days of Future past was everything
I wanted x-men Days of Future past to be
I was entertained I was excited I was
pleased I was touched a couple times I
was like I'm straight-up tearing up cuz
this is good you know I love me the
superhero movies but only if they're
good superhero movies x-men Days of
Future past is not a good superhero
movie x-men Days of Future past is
awesome tacular I don't know how Kitty
Pryde can send people back through time
now walk through walls send people
through time you know they're kind of
synonymous who knows but the movie is
still good
so x-men Days of Future past have you
seen it what did you think about it ever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more